Shack why did you do this I met Barry
during also weekend he was talking about
it long ago three and what really
interested me is that everyone could get
involved usually when you talk about
stocks and IPOs
only the big boys can get involved but
now with 103 everyone can get involved I
mean everyone God is walking to work
every day God is taking the bus everyone
could get involved and I think this will
definitely be a game changer because now
it makes to make some level you'll also
be on the advisory board so what exactly
does that mean are you gonna be a guinea
pig for for new IPOs well no not really
guinea pig you know I'm I'm really gonna
you know helping with strategies and you
know helping with you know getting
people getting people you know of being
aware of the company because you know
not a lot of people know about you know
stuff like this and then you know a lot
of times when you talk to them they say
oh I don't want to do that because of
the fees and all that but yeah but they
need to know and understand loyal 3 no
fees you can invest as little as 10
dollars and again everyone can get
involved with your favorite stocks that
you never really have access to Barry
how do you entice retail investors who
have a ton of other choices like say a
Charles Schwab or a TD Ameritrade first
of all we are fee free and those broker
just charged fees so if you're gonna
invest 25 or 50 or $100 in your pain a
percent to fees that erodes your
potential return a hundred percent of
what you invest in well 3 goes to buying
stock second of all we have access to
IPO s allowing everyday people access to
IPOs such as GoPro and Virgin America
where we did 34% of all the retail
distribution if there's no fees involved
how do you guys make money we make our
money from the issuer we get the spread
on the IPOs and we have a one-time fee
on public companies check you've said
that you invest in companies that do
things that you stand for where did that
social consciousness come from and does
it mean there are times you realize you
in the past might not have made
money on an investment but you were
comfortable because your conscience was
clear well you know based on experience
you know if I do something that I
believed in the return always kicks in
if I do something because I'm trying to
get the quick hit and I've done that a
lot of times on my 20-year career I've
never I've never had a quick hit return
so you know again Google you know when I
was first approached about Google God's
like search engine you could type in a
word I can tell you everything I was
like you know what this the future is
going to work well first approaches
about top top the same thing so when I
met bear and he was telling me that
something like this is going to work and
it's going to work because not everyone
can be involved now everyone can be
involved Shaq you are a fan of buying
hold investing which is very what this
platform is all about tell us about how
your investing philosophy has evolved
over the years because I know in the
early 90s you were very conservative you
only wanted to invest in bonds yes a
very very conservative but again you
know I switched my plan of thought you
know it was something I could change the
game and all that gives that phrase
changing yeah there's something I could
change the game if it's something that
people will relate to something that
people will need it will work again if
I'm trying to get the quick hit by flip
it that you know get the big return
that's never really really work for me
was this something that was always in
the back of your mind because they sack
it mentioned a lot of people don't watch
Business News on television because it's
very very complicated how did you break
this down so the average man and woman
can say you know what maybe that is
something I'd be interested in you want
to make it as easy to buy stock as it is
to buy a product online this is a public
policy issue almost in a way in terms of
allowing more people to have access to
the companies that they believe in and
that they help create value in and it's
great for companies imagine being a CEO
that can say to its employee base and
fan base you all matter to me you've
helped build this company I care about
you so much I'm going to provide access
to my IPO to you same price as Wall
Street and and actually when you're
talking about small investors like this
we're a new channel to create more
capital formation check very quickly you
talked about changing the game evening
the the floor the the playing field do
you think investing in public markets is
rigged
I would use the term raked but you know
it's definitely definitely I don't have
knowledge of what you're doing you know
you definitely have to you know believe
in what you're doing you definitely have
to have trust I don't want to use the
word rigged you know Regas is a very
harsh word
yeah just load it but you know it's a
tricky very tricky so you really have to
know and understand what you're going